[Music]
i thought there could be some nice
symmetry here if um this week of shows
were to end exactly how it began talking
about a subject which i promise i'll
never speak of again after this moment
it's probably true that uh too much has
already been sent about slap gate but
then again it's one of the most
entertaining news events to occur in
many years so you know we're always
kicking one dead horse or another in our
country so why not this one
still even though will smith's assault
of chris rock has been discussed debated
analyzed dissected interpreted examined
scrutinized in every possible way from
every possible angle seemingly there's
one point about the incident that has
not been made or at least not been made
enough or loudly enough and i'd be
remiss if i allowed the week to end and
officially retired from slap gate
discussions without bringing it up and
here's the point
um we know that will smith is a neutered
cuckold prone to violent and
performative rage
that much has been established and he's
received plenty of much-deserved
criticism because of that and also
plenty of not at all deserve support
and yet the biggest villain in this
whole situation the person who shares at
least as much of the blame if not more
has been left off the hook entirely and
that would be will smith's wife
and lots of other men's girlfriend
jada pinkett smith
before we talk about her role in the
slap that will live in infamy we should
take a look at jada's background now
aside from the fact that she's been an
actress for 30 years and has yet to
appear in a good movie in her entire
career
the first thing to establish about jada
pinkett smith is that she's extremely
weird and creepy
so for example here she is a few years
ago talking to her daughter
about how her grandmother taught her
that is taught jada about
self-pleasuring quote unquote at the age
of nine listen
my grandmother taught me
about self-pleasuring because she wanted
me to know that that pleasure was from
me exactly she didn't want me to fall
into the hands of a man and if he gave
me pleasure to think that that was him
and she taught me at nine
look at that woman's
who's i don't know who that woman is in
pink
but she is so excited to hear about a
nine-year-old being taught about
masturbation
so
reflecting back on her experience of
being sexually groomed by her own
grandmother the bizarre lesson that jada
takes away from it is that sex is a
selfish pursuit when a woman is with a
man she says all the pleasure comes from
herself not from the man i'm not even
sure what that means exactly except this
is a twisted depraved woman
but this self-obsessed approach to life
came through i think most profoundly and
embarrassingly when jada sat down with
will smith on camera to discuss in
conspicuously unapologetic terms her
affair with another man a rapper named
august who is only a little bit older
than her son let's go back and watch
that again
as time went on i got into a different
kind of entanglement
with august and one thing i want to get
clear about and clean up one of the
things that was kind of swirling in the
press about
you giving permission which is
uh
you know the only person that can give
permission in in in that particular uh
circumstances myself yes exactly yeah
but what
august was probably trying to
communicate
because i could actually see how he
would perceive it as
permission because we were
separated amicably
and
i think he also wanted to make it clear
that he's not a home wrecker
which he's not i'm thinking so i mean
because this is your red table and you
like brought yourself to the red table
i think um you need to say clearly what
happened as far as what you and i
decided we were gonna
take our space and what happened yeah
and then i got into an entanglement with
august that's what i said an
entanglement yes
yes a relationship yes it was a
relationship absolutely i was in a lot
of pain and i was very broken
that's
maybe the most brutal video clip
in the history of the world that's
really hard to watch
an entanglement she says
and the only thing she cares to clarify
to her husband when it comes to her
sexual entanglements with other men
is that she um she didn't need his
permission to sleep around
also she's the real victim because she
was hurting she was broken
another way to heal her pain was to have
sex with a rapper half her age
you know it's bad enough to be a
backstabbing adulterer in the first
place but jada wasn't satisfied with
that
she also had to traipse her broken shell
of a husband out in front of the cameras
and humiliate him publicly
all part of the fun for her i suppose
but remember she's still a victim in
spite of her awful toxic behavior
because she has alopecia so let's keep
that in mind
that brings us to the fateful night this
past sunday when her husband once again
humiliated himself in front of the world
and uh probably blew up his career in
the process
it was a decision he made uh and he
carries the blame for it but it's fair
to wonder what jada was doing while her
husband was getting up from his seat and
strolling towards the stage it's not
like he got up and ran by the way i mean
he got up and walked so she would have
time to stop him if she was interested
in stopping him how did she react what
was her role in all of this
well somebody in the crowd captured the
immediate aftermath of the slap on their
cell phone and it gives a good view of
how jada responded let's watch that
here is an angle most people have not
seen
look at jada's reaction
so
she's sitting in her seat watching this
all unfold and laughing
that's how she responded by laughing
what kind of wife responds that way as
her husband destroys himself
here's something that all young women
out there ought to know before you get
married okay
part of your job as a wife
is to stop your husband from doing
impulsive self-destructive stupid things
now i'm not saying this is a full-time
job hopefully he won't need
round-the-clock supervision in this
regard teenage boys are a different
matter right i mean they'll find 50
different ways to unintentionally
destroy themselves and ruin their lives
every day but if they survive male
adolescence and make it to adulthood
they'll have probably calmed down
considerably but even so every once in a
while as men we get it into our heads to
do something outlandishly ridiculous and
potentially harmful to ourselves and we
need our wives there to talk some sense
into us
there's a reason why married men live
longer than unmarried men this is the
reason so i'll give one example from my
own life just as an example so as you
heard on the show a few months ago at
one of my recent college talks i decided
to go outside and physically confront a
mob of angry protesters in the street
why did i do this well mostly because i
thought it would be funny and it was
but it was also not the smartest thing
to do from a physical safety perspective
my wife was not there to stop me if she
had been she would have thrown herself
in front of the door to prevent me from
risking my safety for the sake of a joke
she was not able to stop me though she
wasn't there we did we did have a
a discussion about it after the fact and
now every time i have a speech she
implores me not to throw myself into the
middle of any more angry mobs and she
checks in with me repeatedly through the
night to make sure that i am keeping
that promise it kind of ruins my fun to
be honest but
i recognize that she's doing her job as
a wife yeah that's what wives are
supposed to do so i appreciate that
if jada was a good wife who loved her
husband
she would have left up from her chair
grabbed will as he headed to the stage
and said something like what the hell
are you doing
and will would have responded well i'm
gonna go smack chris rock in the face in
the middle of the oscars because he made
fun of you
and jada would have said are you insane
have you lost your mind entirely did you
smoke crack on your way here sit your
ass back down we'll talk about this
later
and then she would have been very sullen
and annoyed for the rest of the night
and after the ceremony will would have
said hey let's go to the after party but
jada would have responded that she's not
in the mood to party and they need to go
home and have a long talk that's the way
it would have played out if this was a
healthy marriage or even just a real
marriage and if jayda was a decent
person and a caring wife
instead she sat there and laughed as her
husband imploded in front of the world
probably enjoyed the whole spectacle
she obviously has a thing for
embarrassing him sure he seems eager to
participate in his own self-debasement
but that's no excuse for jada smith
and so that's why she is today at the
end of the week finally cancelled well i
hope you enjoyed that clip from the matt
wall show if you did go ahead and hit
that subscribe button right down there
so you can stay up to date on all of our
future content